good afternoon
i'm uh
here today joined by
uh acting minister of justice and
solicitor general uh sonia savage and
minister of transportation
uh rajan sani and at edmonton by dr
hinshaw have three issues to address
first of all i'm going to address the
situation with the blockade of the
border crossing at kutz
between alberta and montana and then
secondly provide a brief update of my
uh recent mission to washington dc and
then finally
provide an update on the state of covet
in alberta followed by a statement by
dr hinshaw ministers sani and savage are
available for questions particularly
about the situation
at the border
so
a very serious situation is unfolding at
the border
a week ago
i issued a statement saying that
canadians have a democratic right to
engage in lawful protests
i urge those involved in the truck
convoy protest to do so as safely as
possible
and not to create road hazards which
could lead to accidents or unsafe
conditions for other drivers if
participants in this convoy cross the
line and break the law
i expect police to take appropriate
action
i went on to say that the organizers
should disassociate themselves
immediately from anyone involved in the
convoy who hold or express racist
anti-semitic or bigoted views
canadians have a wide range of
perspectives on the appropriate
government response to the threat of
covet 19 which they are free to express
but we should be united in condemning
bigotry and hatred in all of its forms
and i said thank you to the 90 percent
of albertans including the vast majority
of truckers who protected themselves uh
and our health care system by getting
vaccinated and thank you to the tens of
thousands of truckers who have kept our
economy going over the past two tough
years
we continue to encourage everyone to get
the protection of effective vaccines
finally i said i repeat our call on the
canadian and u s governments to exercise
common sense
by restoring the exemption for
quarantine requirements for unvaccinated
truckers given the huge strains on
supply chains that are forcing up food
prices across the country
well uh there's no doubt that many very
well-intentioned canadians have
participated in protests over the past
week
frustrated by public health measures
that have been designed to pretend to
prevent a catastrophe in our health care
system
but also many specifically focused on
the
requirement for
vaccination for cross-border truckers
between canada
and the united states
and let me say to those vast majority of
lawful
uh protesters uh i hear you i understand
the concerns and frustrations that you
have and for those opposed to the
uh quarantine requirement for cross
borders uh
truckers not only do i hear you but i
agree with you and i went to washington
dc to find allies
to
seek an exemption for the application of
the quarantine requirement for
cross-border truckers from both the
canadian and united states governments
and it is however unfortunate to see a
small number of people who engaged in
protests over the past few days express
extreme
views and embrace hateful symbols
it's also
unfortunate to see a small number break
the law
create a public safety hazard
and
enormous inconvenience for law-abiding
canadians including thousands of other
truckers
by blocking the border at cootes
i was briefed earlier today by
deputy commissioner of the rcmp curtis
oblocki and his senior staff at k
division together with minister savage
minister sani on the situation as it
does as it's unfolding
we were briefed that on saturday
approximately ten thousand trucks and
other vehicles
began a moving convoy around the coots
border station
and police closely monitored the
situation believing at first that it was
an effort to engage in a lawful protest
without blocking the road
let me quote from a statement issued by
the rcmpk division earlier today
what may have begun as a peaceful
assembly quickly turned into an unlawful
blockade
while the alberta rcmp has been in a
position to conduct enforcement we've
been engaged with protesters at the kutz
border crossing in an effort to find a
peaceful and safe resolution for all
involved
we thought we had a path to resolution
the protesters eventually chose not to
comply
as of this morning further action is
being taken by the alberta rcmp as this
blockade continues to impede the ability
for emergency agencies
to provide full services to area
residents it has also negatively
impacted the flow of goods and services
and impedes the public's freedom of
movement
a highway is considered essential
infrastructure it is unlawful to
willfully obstruct interrupt or
interfere with the construction
maintenance use or operation of any
essential infrastructure in a manner
that renders the essential
infrastructure dangerous useless
inoperative or ineffective as per the
critical infrastructure defense act of
alberta
anyone who actively blocks a highway or
aids councils or directs a highway to be
blocked may be subject to arrest and
charge under the act
persons participating in this blockade
can also expect enforcement of any
contraventions of the criminal code the
traffic safety act
and use of highway and rules of road
regulations at this location
and area roadways
so we understand that the rcmp began
enforcement activity earlier today
and um they have done what they can over
the past four days
to seek
a
an agreed-upon approach that would see
an end to the roadblock unfortunately
the approximately 100 remaining
individuals participating in that
process
have apparently refused to
negotiate in good faith with the rcmp
about a an acceptable way
forward i've also received reports
in the last hour of people allied with
the protesters assaulting rcmp officers
including in one instance trying to ram
members of the rcmp
later leading to a collision with a
civilian vehicle
in the area this kind of conduct is
totally unacceptable assaulting law
enforcement officers who are simply
doing their job to maintain public
safety and the rule of law
is completely unacceptable and without
hesitation i condem
those actions and i call for calm
amongst anybody who feels sympathetic
to those engaged in this blockade please
stay away from the area
please do not further intensify an
already difficult situation
the police have a job to do
and
i implore people if you feel strongly
about the issues involved
i invite you encourage you and welcome
you to find peaceful and lawful ways
to make your point clear you have
democratic rights like freedom of
expression freedom of assembly
and freedom of uh of speech and protest
which you can exercise in
countless ways without
creating public safety hazards and
creating this kind of unlawful conflict
albertans respect the rule of law
and
uh all albertans are expected to
respect uh the rules of the road
including those who are participating in
this blockade
thank you to the members of the rcmp
alberta sheriffs and other law
enforcement agencies who are dealing
right now with this very difficult uh
situation as it unfolds
uh and left and thank you to the
thousands and thousands of alberta truck
drivers
who
are abiding by the laws and simply want
to make a living there were some 30 of
those truck drivers who got uh caught up
in the blockade this weekend without
access to food or
in some cases they had medical
conditions and needed medicine uh they
were stranded there for the for the
better part of three days uh thankfully
they were finally released from the
blockade uh but there are thousands of
other law-abiding truck drivers who
simply want to be able safely to do
their jobs to move their goods and if
this blockade continues it will have a
very material impact on our economy both
in terms of import particularly imports
of
key food commodities to canada but also
exports we estimate that some six
billion dollars of exports
pass
from alberta to the united states
primarily through the kutz border
crossing every day that port of entry is
closed uh is represents a cost
particularly to agriculture producers to
livestock producers farmers
and food producers here in alberta we
would like to underscore that there
continued to be opportunities to cross
the border at three other ports of entry
between
alberta and montana on highway 2 at
carway at highway 89 at del bonita
and at highway 41 at
wild horse
i have asked ministers sani and savage
to reach out to the federal minister of
public safety to seek
expanded service and extended hours from
the canada border services agency
and through the government of canada
from the u.s customs and border security
officials
because we can expect that there will
continue to be some interruption at the
coots border crossing perhaps for some
time to come
as the rcmp deals with the road blockage
there and so we are seeking as i say
expanded service at these other border
crossings
and so let me again once once more say
that if you're upset about government
policy u.s government policy canadian
government policy alberta government
policy
that's fine that's your democratic right
but please express it in a peaceful and
law-abiding way and please do not uh add
further a difficulty to an already very
tense situation there at the border
let me then address briefly my recent
mission to washington dc
between friday afternoon and monday
morning of the past weekend
i went to attend the national governors
association annual meeting
had been speaking with a number of
governors last week expressing alberta's
concern
about the
impact of the quarantine requirement for
cross-border truckers and other issues
and a number of them encouraged me to
come down to their uh annual meeting i
had originally planned to do so we we
delayed that because
of omicron but i thought it was very
important that uh there be a canadian
premier there to raise these issues and
other vital uh interests of our province
so i had formal bilateral meetings with
several
u.s governors i chatted at the margins
of the
agm with a number of others and also met
with a key leaders of the u.s business
community of uh unions such as the
teamsters
and uh and think tanks in the united
states to discuss uh our shared concern
about supply chains and particularly uh
these constraints on the trucking
industry but also of course
our the need for
pipelines and energy infrastructure
given that alberta
this year will likely export over 100
billion dollars a year of energy to the
united states and there uh continue to
be efforts to interrupt
a critical export which is so important
to the north american economy and energy
security including
michigan's efforts to
decommission line five
and finally to address uh emerging
protectionism in the united states such
as the buy america provision the country
of origin labeling proposals on
agriculture softwood lumber uh and other
uh aspects of protectionism so it was a
quick but i think a fruitful visit i
certainly didn't meet a single governor
who was supportive of the
canada u.s policy with respect to
the
quarantine requirement for cross-border
truckers and received assurances from
many of my colleagues that they would be
raising this
with the u.s federal administration
finally let me address the current state
of covet 19 in alberta particularly the
omicron variant
we continue to see
encouraging trends with
a continuing decline in the number of
total active cases a gradual decline in
the positivity rate for positive pcr
tests a week ago we were at over 51 000
total
active cases in alberta we're down to 35
000 now
we and we've continued to see a uh
gradual decline in the number of
patients hospitalized in intensive care
units um with covet 19.
we now have a as of today 109 code
patients in intensive care out of a
total of 195
uh total icu patients so operating
slightly above our our baseline capacity
but the trends have been moving in the
right direction with respect to
intensive care for the past two weeks
we however do continue to see a small
increases in the total number of
non-icu coveted patients
uh
we as of today 1 476
patients in non-icu beds across the
system
which represents about 81
of the capacity that is available
and however we do continue to see
stability in the number of overall
uh non-icu beds occupied in our 100
hospital network at a 5
325. so
that's uh that's 80 i should say that's
86
of the non-icu capacity that is occupied
in 81 percent of the icu capacity uh for
for covid so we have
however significant pressure in our
major urban hospitals particularly in
calgary but also in edmonton and
particularly in emergency wards and we
continue to see
unusually high numbers of
frontline workers who have had to stay
home
and are absent because of self-isolation
due to covet infections as well as
our frontline workers just being
exhausted after the
two past incredibly difficult years so
while these overall trends are
encouraging and we clearly did reach the
peak of omicron uh i should omicron
infections approximately two weeks ago
and it appears that we reached the peak
of icu pressures a couple of weeks ago
um we are not out of the woods yet and i
implore albertans to continue uh to be
mindful of this of the pressure on our
health care system
uh so as frustrated as as uh everybody
is with um
the the two years of covet in our lives
affecting so much
of what we do every single day we need
to continue to be careful and mindful of
the nurses and doctors and other
frontline health care workers who
continue to operate under real stress
now we continue to monitor these these
numbers very closely as i've said before
once we begin to see a
sustained reduction
in
covert pressure on the hospitals
i
am looking forward to
being able to make decisions about
moving towards relaxation of public
health measures at that time and i
believe that will happen
this month in february
we see a
sustained decline in hospitalization
pressure
but with the overall trends i am very
optimistic
that we will be able to move forward
with meaningful uh relaxation of public
health measures this month including the
elimination of the restriction exemption
or proof of vaccination program
so
i just asked people to be a little more
patient as
we we are still at a record high number
uh for non-icu uh covet hospital
admissions we need to see those numbers
start to come down
and then i am confident we'll be able to
move forward uh safely and prudently uh
with uh reducing uh the burden of public
health measures on albertans and with
that i'll invite dr hinshaw for her
remarks and then happy to take your
questions
thank you premier and good afternoon
everyone
as you've noticed we unfortunately do
not have sign language interpreters
available today
i apologize for the inconvenience this
causes for any deaf and hard of hearing
albertans
a full transcript of my remarks will be
posted to alberta.ca tomorrow morning
and a summary of my update will be
shared on my twitter account later today
turning to today's update
over the last 24 hours we have
identified
1980 new cases of covet 19 and completed
about 5 000 tests
our positivity rate for lab confirmed
cases was very high yesterday at about
40 percent although our seven day
average is slowly declining
our hospitalizations for covet 19 may be
beginning to plateau although it is
important to note they are still
currently higher than at any other time
in the pandemic
there are currently one thousand five
hundred eighty-five people total with
covet 19 in hospital which includes 109
in the icu
sadly more albertans continue to lose
their lives to this virus
over the last 24 hours 13 new deaths
have been reported to alberta health
my sympathy goes out to the family and
friends of these individuals and to
anyone who has lost a loved one no
matter the cause
each of these deaths and every life lost
in alberta to this virus is a reminder
of the serious nature of covet 19 and
the tremendous impact it continues to
have on our communities our friends and
our families
while our leading indicators of
wastewater surveillance and positivity
are signaling that we are on the other
side of the fifth wave and it is
encouraging to see that hospitalizations
may be at a plateau
at the same time it is critical to
remember that half of all of our cases
come in the second part of the wave and
transmission is still very high
that is why we must all continue to look
after one another especially those most
at risk of serious outcomes from the
virus
the majority of us have a relatively low
risk of severe outcomes due to a number
of factors that can include vaccination
status younger age and the absence of
pre-existing medical conditions but that
doesn't apply to everyone
i'm sure each of us has several people
in our lives about whom we care deeply
who are at increased risk of severe
outcomes
this could be an elderly parent or
grandparent a friend battling cancer a
newborn niece or a sister with a
compromised immune system
whoever they are i believe we would do
whatever we can to keep them safe
which includes doing our part to stop
chains of transmission
by thinking of these people and taking
steps to help protect them from covet 19
we can also help the broader community
get through this fifth wave
it's also important to remember that the
health care system is still under
significant strain
this means that any one of us who needs
care for any reason should expect that
the system might be a little slower
right now
please don't delay seeking help if you
are sick but also please be patient with
the health care workers who are doing
everything they can to keep the system
running under incredible pressure
all of us can do our part to help our
frontline healthcare workers by taking
actions that not just reduce our risk
but our communities risk as well
thank you for getting fully vaccinated
and boosted
thank you for staying home when you're
sick
thank you for following the public
health measures
another tool in our fight against
covid19 is rapid tests and i'm pleased
to share this week that more than 3.1
million rapid tests will be sent to
first nations communities
pharmacies in calgary edmonton and red
deer and alberta health services sites
in other parts of the province
you can check the blue cross website
that lists which locations have rapid
test kits available
when you find a site that does have
tests simply bring your id and alberta
healthcare card to receive a free kit
in addition to these tests for the
general public a second mask and test
shipment for schools started last week
and approximately one-third have already
gone out
with respect to covid19 impacts on
schools alberta education has provided
the following update
as of january 31st
22 of the more than 2 500 schools in
alberta have shifted to temporary
at-home learning to address operational
challenges which means less than one
percent of schools are currently
operating online
six of these schools have less than 40
students in total
lastly i want to speak briefly about
seasonal influenza as alberta is still
in flu season
after recording zero cases of seasonal
influenza last year
influenza is again circulating in our
communities
thankfully so far our labs have only
confirmed 39 influenza cases and one
person has been hospitalized due to
seasonal influenza
while that's a very small number
compared to previous years more cases of
influenza would put further strain on
alberta's healthcare system and
healthcare workers who are doing
everything they can to support the
health of albertans
by keeping the number of influenza cases
and outbreaks low we can help protect
at-risk albertans and reduce the
pressure on our healthcare system
influenza vaccine doses including flu
zone high dose for seniors 65 and older
are still widely available across the
province with many pharmacies accepting
walk-ins
albertans can also book an appointment
online at bookvaccine.alberta.ca
or phone your local pharmacy or
participating doctor's office for
availability
whether it's preventing the spread of
influenza or covid or reaching out to
help people who need support in any part
of their lives
each of us makes a difference in our
actions every day
thank you for doing your part to help
our communities
thank you and we're happy to take
questions
thank you dr hinshaw that concludes the
formal portion of today's announcement
we're now going to move over to
immediate q a and just a reminder to any
journalist online that we also have
minister savage the acting minister of
justice and mr sani alberta's minister
of transportation available for
questions as well
as we do quite a few people in the queue
i'd ask that you please keep yourself to
one question one follow-up and please
try to keep your questions as brief as
you can so we can get to as many
questions as possible with that operator
can you please put through our first
call
david staples edmonton journal
you for taking my call um
uh premier kenny you mentioned that
later this month
you might be we might be in a position
where you can lift
restrictions what would be the trends
and you know triggers what would be the
numbers in hospital and icu that would
indicate that we're ready to do that and
are you talking about lifting
all of the restrictions like you
mentioned the rep are you talking about
masking
and also um you know restrictions on um
size of events let's say orders and
flame schemes
thank you david so uh we don't have uh
specific metrics we are going to be
looking at the overall trends altogether
of course the infection trends with
respect to positivity the wastewater
data the total active cases
but more specifically the
hospitalization numbers uh we have seen
a decline
of pressure on intensive care
and thankfully omicron the omicron wave
has
never posed the kind of threat to
our intensive care awards that delta did
so we're now just slightly above our
baseline icu capacity uh that's
encouraging uh the one figure we need to
start to see moving in the right
direction would be
the non-icu hospitalizations
now um the last few days bouncing around
1500
i should
underscore that
about 40 percent of those are incidental
and not primary covet infections so
about
630 of the current
uh
this is based on the ratios we haven't
done genome sequencing for every single
one of those 1500 patients but based on
the the ratios and the trends that we
have seen
we estimate that a little over 600 of
those and non-icu code patients are um
not in hospital primarily
for due to covet
so about 900 are
and we we really need to see that number
start to come down
we frankly
it is our belief
when i look at
the alberta health services early
warning
system
uh it's our belief that we are likely
now
at or around the peak of those non-icu
coveted hospitalizations but we need to
see that for sure
so we'll be monitoring that trend line
with particular attention
because you know as long as that number
is that high david um
we it means that we are continuing to
see some postponement of surgeries and
other medical procedures we're operating
about 85 percent
of our typical surgical capacity right
now
um i'd obviously like to see that come
closer to 100
uh and then we i will be able i think uh
very seriously to consider uh uh
relaxing measures you asked if that
would happen all at once i i don't uh
the scenarios that we are considering
would be uh
to move in in something like three
phases uh in the relaxation of measures
um
to uh ensure that we don't trip back
into positive growth and additional
pressure on the hospitals starting from
a pretty high baseline so we will do
this in a in a thoughtful and careful
way
driven by the data
but
one thing that i
believe will be
eliminating
quickly in in the first wave
is the restriction exemption program
and and that is because um
as you as you know
the
lag effect on the full series of
vaccines for most people to uh uh
if we're now over six months for most of
those people means that um
that's that's that vaccination status is
having uh
is being less helpful in preventing
transmission and infection than was the
case when we brought in the rep uh in
early september
so um i would that is something that i
would hope and expect for us to be
eliminating in the first phase of
relaxing measures uh but again we'll
need to see the hospital numbers start
to come down
and david you have a follow-up today
yes thank you
um
last week uh premier you indicated that
the hospitalization numbers weren't that
different than the peaks we saw in other
kind of winter cold flu seasons i think
in 2018 and 2019.
we didn't have lockdowns then so i'm
just wondering why we have them now when
the hospitals
at least based on those numbers aren't
more stressed than they were 2018 and
and in 2019
so different now that this is locked out
thanks dave
overall
it's true that we have had higher total
levels of hospitalization in the past i
pointed that out in in um
two of the three years in preceding
covid
we saw higher total non-icu
hospitalizations
the system that we do today however
that was not uh primarily because of the
flu
uh or influenza it was because of other
uh things happening in the system so i'm
sure dr israel will rush well we'll
will want to point out pardon me
that um at the peak of
our worst
flu season in recent years uh doctor
please jump in you'll correct me but i
think we're at about 450
uh flu-related hospitalizations right
now we're at about 1500
non-icu covert hospitalizations even if
you discount from that the roughly 600
that are incidental called
hospitalizations we are still about
twice as high now
with non-icu hospitalizations as we
would have been at our historic peak of
influenza hospitalization so covet is
having a significantly larger impact
also important david that even for those
incidental cases they they can't be kind
of dismissed as an as not being a
pressure point because
of of omicron's effectiveness
um
those patients do require a special
isolation protocols they take up more
space more rooms more beds
and uh more time for hospital workers
and with respect to ppe and other
protocols so
those 600 or so
non-icu incidental omicron
patients in acute care beds
do also represent an additional pressure
and then finally david what's
i think most
significant or what's most different
about the current
hospital pressure versus uh flu season
in previous years would be two years of
of fatigue two years of just exhaustion
operating at a very high tempo for our
healthcare workers in addition to a
higher than normal level of people who
are
of healthcare workers who are in
isolation uh unable to work so you put
all those things together and you've got
uh maybe numerically not the same
pressure as before but but greater
challenges and dr incha would you like
to comment on that
i think you've covered it certainly the
fact that we've had four substantial and
uh significantly higher waves than any
recent influenza season in just over a
year
has a cumulative effect and then the one
number i would add to the number that
you provided is that our peak icu
influenza inpatient number at any point
in the three years prior to the pandemic
our highest level was 38 influenza
patients in icu at any given time across
the province so even though 109 patients
is lower than we've seen with previous
waves it's still more than double what
we've seen at the peak of a bad
influenza season previous to covet so
again further to your point premiere um
while uh
it is the system is managing its
managing by
shifting
people and services and uh part of the
ways that they're keeping inpatient
burden manageable is by decreasing
surgery volumes and other interventions
so this is definitely different than an
influenza year
thank you operator can you please
connect our next
call our next question comes from andrew
lawton true north
good evening premier tomorrow
conservative leader at the federal level
aaron o'toole is facing a vote
among his caucus on whether he should be
ousted as leader you endorsed him in
2020 when he was seeking the leadership
uh what are your thoughts does he
deserve to stay on as conservative
leader federally
uh well thanks andrew i've got to say
i'm pretty focused on a number of very
difficult issues here right now
uh not getting caught up in federal
politics i'll just say this to my
friends in the federal conservative
party i i don't think in the long run uh
it makes sense to change leaders after
every election i think uh
stability and continuity are important
conservative principles i also would
just encourage my friends in the federal
conservative party not to do or say
things right now in the heat of the
moment that they might end up regretting
on either side of this debate i think
what the public expects is for
the opposition to hold the government to
account
and so i would encourage my friends as
much as possible to keep their their
political fire trained on on the
government and that and to remember to
remember what whatev whatever
differences they may have uh those
differences pale in comparison
to the differences they have with the uh
with the governing party
and uh to focus on those things that
unite them not those issues that divide
them
so that would be my encouragement uh
just to be patient with one another uh
and um and and seek through this at a
difficult time
to to be respectful and patient of each
other not to say things that they might
end up programming regretting six or
months or a year down the road
and and here a follow-up today
yes
you have been very clear in your
condemnation of the incidents we have
seen uh the extreme symbols and rhetoric
from some of the people aligned aligning
themselves with the convoy movement
generally speaking do you see the convoy
in ottawa right now as a peaceful
protest
i i'm not on the ground hard for me to
to make that call i would
say that
what we're i'm focused on is is right
now the coots border crossing here in
alberta
it is um
unlawful
it
blocking a highway creates a public
safety hazard
it could impede the movement of
emergency service vehicles
and uh we have now received reports
of rcmp officers uh being swarmed and
an effort to
ram officers uh trying to enforce a
barricade
that's not peaceful
so
in our situation here in alberta i i
once again would plea
for calm
and ask folks who may whose tempers may
be running high
to channel that frustration into
peaceful and lawful protest
rather than
what we've been seeing today
in southern alberta
thank you operator can you please pick
through our next call
kevin gallagher ctv
hello premier actually to follow up on
mr lawton's question there um
uh
premier ford was asked this today but if
there was a vacancy in the federal
leadership would you consider it of the
conservative party
no
i am so completely focused on these
incredibly huge challenges we're facing
right now that's uh that's not of any
interest to me and i once again i'll
just say i do hope that
my friends in the conservative party of
canada will find a way to
work through their process
with as much respect for their
colleagues as they can uh and just
remember that at the end of the day um
they've got to be united and canadians
are counting on them to be an effective
opposition uh and the best way to do
that is to be united and kevin do you
have a follow-up today
uh just i want to clarify so the
illegal
blockade at kutz
do you find that it no way compares to
the blockade of streets in
ottawa i know that you mentioned
emergency vehicles i just want to be
clear that you were talking about
emergency vehicles in alberta and not in
ottawa i didn't know what you were
trying to say i'm sorry um what i was
speaking i said look i'm not on the
ground in ottawa i i
am not following hour-by-hour reports so
i'm just not in a position to offer an
informed view about what's going on
there um i would just say generally my
impression is over the past week we've
had a lot of protests and a lot of
different people and i think the vast
majority of them
are well-intentioned law-abiding
canadians who are sick and tired
of
how covet has turned their lives upside
down
they're frustrated with all kinds of
public health measures
and in many are frustrated in particular
with the quarantine requirement for uh
cross-border truckers so to those folks
who've been out there trying to make
that point peacefully and and
respectfully uh thank you thank you for
um using your democratic rights
to do that thank you for
sharing your your passion and your
frustration um and i certainly hear you
uh
to those here in alberta who have
participated in or supported
some of these protests um
specifically i want to say to them
i am very sympathetic
i'm leading the government that has
repeatedly been attacked for having
treated restrictions as a lasting
limited resort
but
please understand we've only ever
resorted to restrictions when the
alternative was
overwhelming our health care system and
potentially
having to pull life support from people
in our intensive care awards or
canceling even more surgeries and
medical procedures which would hurt even
more people please to folks who are so
frustrated i sure
by god i share the frustration
please understand that um we
have
tried to
take a minimal approach to restrictions
but a necessary one
to avoid even more damaging
cancellations of surgeries
uh and uh
and and
loss of life
from covet 19. please understand there
have been no good choices in any of this
so to folks who are motivated by that
frustration
um
i totally sympathize with that
but uh please express that in a way
that uh is lawful and peaceful
uh
uh and please
you know don't make a bad situation
worse i'm out there trying to campaign
to end the
quarantine requirement for unvaccinated
cross-border truckers i went down to
washington
in large part to make that case i've
made it to the prime minister i will
continue to
so for those who feel that way i'm on
your side
but part of the argument we're making
there is that um
the restriction on uh unvaccinated truck
drivers doesn't make sense and it's
gonna further force up food prices and
create challenges for supplies and
including food
so that's exactly what's happening at
the coots border crossing right now
uh so
you know i think the more persuasive way
to make the case
um is
is in a in a law-abiding way
let's work together to make this point
for common sense when it comes to
that trucker vaccine mandate and i'm
certainly on site on that
okay operator can you please connect our
next call
rick bell calgary sun
good afternoon premier and ministers and
dr henshaw
uh quick uh two two quick questions and
i'll keep them short first one is
it's no secret premiere that there are a
lot of people who don't trust
governments and politicians these days
including
some people not even trusting this
government
are you going to come out with following
a question i think mr staples had
are you at some point going to come out
with some sort of concrete road map
blueprint timeline
which tells us
when things happen leading us to the
end goal
of the removal of all restrictions
because
right now the way i'm hearing you it
sounds except for the vaccine passport
sounds very vague i even feel like
cancelling my st patrick's day party
um
so
is there going to be a time you're
actually going to come out and
concretely say
this is
where we're going and this is where we
anticipate things to be
to give you a much more concrete answer
on the removal of restrictions period
the answer rick is yes
uh we will do that
um
uh i anticipate
in the near future within days i'm
hopeful that we'll be able to come out
and provide
that framework but we've not we've got
to start to see some hospital numbers
start to move down
so
we want to move quickly
and concretely
to lift the burden
of these damaging restrictions
we want to do it in a way that's safe
and i will be presenting more
information as early as next week on
that
and rick your follow-up
yes the follow-up is
um
what do you say to the majority of
albertans at least the majority of
albertans who were pulled in a recent
anguish free poll
and even many of your mlas and many of
your party supporters what do you say to
those people who believe that
restrictions should be
removed
pretty quickly some say now some say
quite quickly
and if you don't agree with them and
think that maybe we have to take a
little more time what is it that the
majority of what what is it you believe
the majority of albertans including some
of your mlas are not understanding
well rick actually i i do agree with
that sentiment
uh i uh
please take yes for an answer
and
let me remind you that this is a
government that has been
criticized from day one
for
looking at restrictions as a last and
limited resort and lifting them as soon
as we could
we will lift these restrictions as soon
as it is prudent to do so
and i think that starts quite soon i
know we're not a position to give you a
specific date because rick we are still
at the peak of our hospitalizations for
from covet for the past two years
so we have to do this in um
in a thoughtful way
that's what we will do
and i believe we'll be able to provide a
a framework
for widespread relaxation of
public
health measures and rules as early as
next week
and that the restriction exemption
program will be at the top of that list
but
we need to uh you know we are very we
have one
uh one of the many advantages we have
is the ability to see what's going on in
other parts of the world that hit
omicron before we did
so the united kingdom or england at
least um and then ireland
and now denmark
south africa a number of of european
countries in addition to the three i
mentioned they have
uh
in the last week or so
lifted all or almost all public health
measures
so we're going to be able to see uh what
impact that has in those jurisdictions
and that will help to
guide our decisions in the next week or
so
and
so i think that's that's a benefit we
have we can watch our own
hospitalization data but also see the uh
the impact of what happens in those
jurisdictions and
my hunch right now
is you're going to continue to see
uh
in those places that have
that are ahead of us on the omicron
curve
i think you're going to see that uh
the wave continues to go down in most
cases now denmark
a slightly different situation because
they got a new variant coming in on top
of omicron but even though their case
numbers are very high their
hospitalization numbers are manageable
and that's why they've gone to almost
eliminate almost all public health
measures so we're keeping an eye on that
but really the key number here
is the total number on on
hospitalizations uh we've got to start
to see that come down that's the key
thing to watch
okay thank you premier operator can you
please connect our next call
alex mcquaid western producer
uh this is the question thanks uh this
is the question for the premier uh are
you willing to meet with the protesters
in coos
well i
there look there's an rcmp enforcement
action going on right there and i'm not
going to cross-thread myself with
the operational decisions of the police
i think that would be um
unhelpful uh we in this country
part of the rule of law means that uh we
trust the judgment
of our law enforcement agencies on
operational matters and for a politician
to get cross-threaded into that i don't
think would be helpful um
but um
let me tell you
the rcmp did attempt
to have a dialogue
they had their uh
their specialists in engaging
uh protest groups uh down there
and i and they thought they were getting
somewhere
on uh
particularly last night
they
as you know the rcmp's approach and i
think most police services these days
they they've got a lot of training in
de-escalation in trying to de-conflict
situations like this their first op
their first choice is very rarely to go
straight into enforcement
for all sorts of obvious reasons and i
respect that um and so the rcmp i'm
briefed by deputy uh commissioner
zablocki
uh they um they tried over
uh
the past couple of days
to to come to an understanding with the
people involved in the blockade but
ultimately found
that there was
no interest
in cooperating to quote exactly from
their statement of earlier today
they said that um
uh
they said that um we have been engaged
with protesters at the coots border
crossing in an effort to find a peaceful
and safe resolution for all involved
we thought we had a path to resolution
but the protesters eventually chose not
to comply
so that is where it's at and we will
respect the operational decisions that
the police services make
and alex do you have a follow-up today
uh yes on a different topic same uh a
question for the premier again is uh
there's in the agricultural sector there
is some concern about
what's happening uh their ability to get
supplies into ship supplies over the
border
are there
any more supports available for
agricultural producers to uh deal with
current situations if it drags on much
longer
we'll take a look at that i think it's
very early uh and i'm not aware of any
requests that have come to the minister
of agriculture but uh minister horner is
in constant contact i do know he is very
concerned about the movement of beef
products and in particular because
obviously
uh the spoilability there and so that's
a just-in-time
kind of industry um then there's huge
back and forth cross-border
uh trade in um in cattle in
beef processing
so um and i know that there are a lot of
trucks filled up ready to roll south
that are unable to do so
that's why i've asked our ministers to
work with cbsa to see if we can provide
for better uh border crossing service
with the americans at the three other uh
canada us border crossings in alberta
but if this goes on i mean if we were to
see a sustained
um blockage of american markets then
then yeah we would take a look at
whether we could uh whether to provide
additional support to ag exporters at
this point we don't think that's uh
uh that's we just need to get this
border open uh as soon as possible and
get back to
being able to let people make a living
okay we have time for about four or five
more calls today uh operator can you
please put through our next call
lisa corbella post media
good afternoon um
i guess this is a question for either
minister savage or minister sani about
uh the suspension of the provincial
administration uh penalties act and so i
guess uh the question is how significant
were the letters and calls that the
government received and that mlas
received from concerned albertans about
you know the proposed legislation that
would have stripped some of their
constitutional right to the presumption
of innocence
and you know other measures of
procedural fairness before the court so
how many letters did you
receive or did the government receive
and um how significant were those
for the
suspension of this legislation
good afternoon alicia thank you for that
question first of all i do want to say
that the initial
reports about phase 2 jti phase 2
were in the media as a result of a
leaked document and they weren't
necessarily reflective of what phase 2
was going to look like
made the decision to suspend that until
we did some further engagement
we did hear extensively from albertans
through our constituency offices as well
as foreign ministry offices
time and did more engagement with all
kinds of stakeholders to make sure that
when we do introduce this program that
we get it right and we address some of
those key issues that were brought up
and lisa do you have a follow-up today
i do
um
so i guess the question is uh first of
all i think a lot of albertans find it
pretty difficult to believe that like
today that that new law would have come
out right
february 1st that's when it was and so
you're saying that the the
the legislation that we as albertans
could see online was not actually what
you were planning on putting forward but
things like it i don't know i find that
difficult to believe but anyway here's
my question
given that those letters and concerns of
albertans um
were so plentiful and you never did
answer how many there were so i'd like
to have an answer that first question
um can you assure us now that albertan's
constitutional right to the presumption
of innocence will be maintained in new
legislation
so just to just to backtrack a little
bit
february first was to be the
implementation date but there was work
being done within the department to
address specific aspects of the program
including the fees and when the story
first came out i believe it was in early
january so
that is the reality that we were doing
additional policy work prior to
implementation
in regards to the exact number of
letters received or communications
received i would have to go back to the
constituency offices and compile that
information i'd be happy to share that
with you
as soon as i get that information
together
so
next steps include addressing some of
the issues that were brought up by
albertans including what you had just
mentioned about constitutional rights
and other issues around the fees and
quite frankly we have to do a better job
of communicating what this program is
all about we have a tremendous backlog
in the courts that is impeding other
criminal matters from being fully
investigated and going to trial and that
was the whole intention behind this
program but going forward there is going
to be more engagement done and we will
address those key issues that were
brought up
thank you minister operator can you
please put through our next call
chris barco calgary hills
hi this is a question for the premier
premier you attended the governor's
meeting in washington on the weekend and
you said you mentioned in your
earlier remarks that you had some
discussions regarding line five i guess
i'm wondering what kind of support were
you finding
or a candidate's position on line five
with the us governor and did you have a
chance at all to have a discussion with
any of the officials or the governor
from michigan
so
i probably discussed line five with
about a dozen u.s governors and they
were all
hugely supportive of our position uh
unfortunately i did not have a chance to
meet with governor whitmer we did ask
for a meeting but i'll tell you going
back two years uh effectively she's
refused to talk to us about line five
i was actually i went to michigan in
september of 2019
and sought to meet with her in lansing
but
she refused to do so i did meet uh state
house leaders uh from both the
democratic republic and there was a lot
of support for continuing for enbridge's
plan to
replace
the current pipe
with
a new uh subterranean uh and high-tech
safe pipeline
um
one of our
part of our strategy has been
to engage governors and state leaders in
the uh in this in the surrounding states
like ohio
uh and indiana uh as well as michigan
because it's it's hugely important to
all of them as well
and uh i did chat again with the ohio
governor mike dewine about it this past
weekend he's a good friend of alberta
i visited one of the refineries in
upstate ohio
in september of 2019 just to underscore
which is completely fueled by line five
and it's cooperated by
um by husky or it was at the time so
you've got you can see the very big
alberta footprint there
the governors are very familiar with it
and basically
and by the way not just the governors
but the unions
i mean yesterday i spoke i met with um
the uh
with president of the north american
building trades union
as well as the president of the
teamsters jimmy hoffa jr
and they both raised line five before i
could
uh because
they understand how important the
project is us chamber of commerce the
same thing uh the center for strategic
uh studies uh same thing so
people in washington are very aware and
the folks i engage with none of them can
understand why the body administration
doesn't get off the fence
and support enbridge's plan
rather than be neutral about an effort
by the governor there to um
to decommission it
particularly in the context where the
buy administration is pleading with opec
to increase exploration and production
so we have a lot of allies um at least
the us state department is sitting down
finally and talking to
canada
uh about the uh
about line five in the context of the
bilateral pipeline treaty uh since
canada triggered the complete the uh
dispute resolution mechanism on that in
december
and chris do you have a follow-up today
uh yes i do uh premiere back in december
you talked about rolling out or
potentially rolling out programs to
protect albertans from increases in gas
and power prices we're seeing alberta
power prices averaging 90 megawatt hours
so far this year we've got uh alberta
natural gas over five dollars
uh and i guess i'm wondering with the
inflationary pressures going on as well
what is your government prepared to do
to help albertans with these
inflationary costs and these rising
energy
expenses what options are you willing to
consider
well we have been looking at a potential
uh rebate on uh natural gas
prices should they reach a
a a very high level that
based on what the client government did
in the past we estimate that on an
inflation-adjusted basis that rebate
would kick in at about 6.50 cents
uh
above where we are now so we've done
work on that um until you know just
until the past week or so as you know
because the prices have been
um
have been
you know close
closer to three dollars so there has
been a significant increase we're
watching that very closely
and if these prices go significantly
higher we are prepared to provide
some support
as has happened in alberta in the past
thank you premier operator can you
please put through our next call
kelly carterman global mail
hi there um i hope you're all doing well
or okay i just wanted to
um ask the premier whether he still
supports aaron o'toole as leader of the
conservative party of canada
yes i'm sorry i thought i made that
clear earlier
and as i said before i think it's not in
the interests of of any party just to
constantly change leaders every election
cycle and uh i think uh i just hope that
all of my friends in the federal
conservative party um approach this with
mutual respect patience and civility and
ultimately stay focused on the
importance of unity
and kelly do you have a follow-up today
yes i do i'm wondering on what guidance
you've given to mlas about going to coup
to support the protesters at all and
whether
whether you've had a discussion with
grant hunter about his appearance there
earlier
yeah i did speak to mr hunter and
expressed concern
about his presence there on saturday
grant explained to me that he went down
to meet constituents it is in his
constituency wanted to see what's going
on
and it was his intention to to show
uh moral support for
law-abiding and peaceful protesters he
said that while he was there
there was no blockade of the highway
and
that seems confirmed to me when i was
briefed earlier by the rcmp who
indicated that
through most of saturday
the
convoy was operating as a as a loop it
was a moving convoy and the rcp was
trying to work with that um to
facilitate a peaceful uh
protest
uh and as you know
mr hunter has issued a statement
um
underscoring that he uh while he's
sympathetic to many of the messages of
the protesters he does not support
unlawful protest
so um
that i i i appreciate his uh clarity on
that and obviously i would say to
anybody who's uh
involved in the business of being a
legislator of making the law uh that we
have to respect the rule of law
thank you premier operator can you
please connect our pen ultimate call for
today
jesse weiser and
right global tv
hi thanks for taking my question uh this
is for the premier uh at any point over
the last four days did your government
consider going to the courts to seek an
injunction against the blockade
no that's not advice that we received in
fact um
we
[Music]
made it clear that should that be
helpful to the law enforcement agencies
we would be prepared to do so but you
know we don't need an injunction
simply to enforce the law the law is
very clear
not just
the
defense of critical infrastructure act
but the uh multiple the criminal code
there are multiple criminal code
provisions here
um
the traffic safety act the use of
highway and rules of the road
regulations all of things these things
are perfectly clear so you don't need a
judge to empower the police simply to
enforce
um regulations or
the law and now
uh
i've as i've said before we've seen
blockades of
critical infrastructure i understand
that
the police
have to make a judgment call
about how best to address
a situation and that often
that doesn't trigger automatic
enforcement right away
because they they do
because they're concerned that that some
sometimes will make the situation worse
and actually prolong the blockade or the
protest so i i understand respect uh the
need for operational discretion on the
part of police
um but they have all the legal
tools that they need at their disposal
and i would like to say i think this is
a validation
of the critical infrastructure defense
act uh the bill one of uh the
legislature last year
that was passed really anticipating
blockades of this nature it was much
derided
um but this is exactly what it was
intended for which is to say
you you can't uh render useless or
dangerous or inoperative critical
infrastructure like this uh minister
sanderson would you like to add to this
sure thank you premier we did take a
take a look at
the necessity of an injunction and given
that the police are taking action um
we've determined it's not necessary at
this time of course all ground
operational matters on enforcement and
whether whether delayed charges and if
so what charges are decisions made by
the law enforcement um just to know this
is a very volatile and evolving
situation and those decisions are best
made by the law enforcement but at this
point we are not looking at an
injunction because it's not necessary
thank you minister uh jesse do you have
a follow-up today
i do thanks minister and premier uh this
next question is for dr hinshaw
we've seen what appears to be growing
numbers of fatalities in the last week
including some without pre-existing
conditions in their 20s and 30s how does
vaccination status factor into the
fatalities we're seeing and from the
data you've seen from the people in
hospital is omicron still showing to be
more mild
there's a difference between the
individual risk of severe outcomes with
an omicron infection and the population
level impact it has given how widespread
it has become
so we know from all of the waves we've
had the earliest indicators are cases
positivity we now have wastewater
surveillance that's an early indicator
of transmission
when we see those start to rise there's
usually a bit of a lag and then we start
to see some increases in
acute care impacts both icu and non-icu
and the deaths that kovid causes are the
kind of
tail end of some of those impacts so we
are starting to see the impacts of
omicron spread
we know that
those who were unvaccinated have the
highest risk of severe outcomes
including death
and
particularly those who
uh
have chronic conditions again they're
they're greater risk but somebody even
without chronic conditions if they have
no vaccine protection
and they
are exposed to covid they can have a
fatal outcome
we have been monitoring our
overall outcomes including
hospitalizations and deaths very closely
we know that vaccination status is very
protective but we also know with how
widespread omicron has become in the
population
it's not surprising that we would see
that impact in fatalities it's
unfortunate again
each loss is tragic each person matters
and
we are doing our best with the
vaccination program to make sure people
have access to that kind of protection
encouraging people to step up and get
their vaccines including boosters so we
can do our best to stop chains of
transmission as well as the public
health measures currently in place which
all are aimed at minimizing these severe
outcomes such as deaths including the um
the ones that you mentioned that have
been rising lately as a later indicator
of our omicron wave
thank you dr hinshaw operator can you
please connect our final call for the
day
julian now traverse radio canada
yes thank
[Music]
[Music]
thank you premier ministers and dr
himself that wraps things up for today